I'm going to invite you into unexplored
Terrain
now unexplored terrain by definition
is the space
of
first sight
the space of first sight
not yet
encumbered
not yet ruined
by familiarity
The Place Beyond
our Maps
is the place
in which
we die to all of our stories and return
once more to the place where dreams are
born I am
speaking about the threshold Crossing
where the mind takes flight and the self
is obliterated and you stare into the
abyss and the abyss stares into you why
do we love films like Avatar and
Interstellar what Thrills do they awaken
within us what space and place do they
remind us of what recognition takes
place of a kind of liftoff into the land
of far away and the place not yet
explored the manic geometries the
astounding Frontier of the present
moment the place and space that takes
your breath away as you you feel your
legs shake and shudder you find yourself
once more in virginal terrain like a
child in Flight attention abrupt
framed it is a moment that lifts you up
it is a moment of crossing over it is a
threshold Crossing in which you in which
you peer once more at the abyss
and you know once more to be born again
see there is a
losing of one's footing an intentional
lostness that hurls us finally to the
place that has no name the psychologist
Otto rank I think his name is describes
this encounter as an experience and a
direct confrontation with the mysterium
tremendum Joseph Campbell the
mythologist says it's the place where
myths are born it is the ultimate Bliss
[__] crucifixion as Janie wheel says
where the curtain parts and what had
never been seen is at once devoured by
the eyes you are subsumed by the
experience you are obliterated by The
Experience You Are transfigurated by the
experience you are hurled into the abyss
and you are in the space that has no
name down the rabbit hole and Through
the Looking Glass and Through the
Wormhole and space and time Collide and
the astounding Frontier of the present
emerges from the pixelating wake of a
kind of annihilatory crystallized
whoa Baseline reality
dissolves and like a solo in the song by
a psychedelic rock band you are hurled
into a Magic Carpet Ride a guitar solo a
rift Beyond time and place you are
falling you are hurling you are flying
you are sliding you are in a topsy-turvy
world inside out and outside outside in
you are Alice and you've just had some
kind of mushroom and the world is being
remade
before your very eyes and why do I love
this experience
why do I live
for these
transubstantiations
well it's very simple friends
it provides me
with a
with Terence Mechanicals the felt
reality of direct experience
I am
by losing track of my boundaries
by losing track of my edges by
forgetting where I end and where the
other begins I am expanded I am remade I
am reborn but if you can just hold on to
the let go hold on to the surrender like
like trust fall through the experience
you arrive at a place
that brings you back to life
in a way that can't be languished